I wanted Marshall but turned out my
microphone before we get started how are
you before we get started you just down
the hall but happy birthday Susie I was
yesterday
happy birthday I didn't get a chance to
say it so you know it sonic it kind of
got lost in Tom Brady's 40th it happened
Marshall fault it happens nice here rich
well I dunno about you you stole the but
you stumbled upon something Marshall
because rich is getting some blowback
Teddy I don't know chinking about
shaving it a night
now look look I'm telling you it I went
through this it takes a minute for them
to get used to seeing you with it I have
had people who I've known for a very
very long time just within the last 20
minutes not recognized me what lega who
that were fect Jimmy Johnson had no idea
who the hell I was Johnson's in his own
right now I heard that it got hanging
out here with the Sunday Night Football
crew the man who created Sunday Night
Football on NBC Dick Ebersol he's here
didn't read known him for years
walked up to him no idea what the hell I
was look at you and then he you know to
go with it
it's another face something you have a
new second new phase of evolution really
understand it has to evolve like the
flight it's like LeBron going to like
the different jerseys you know in July
annexing in right 23 your local branch a
whole have you been in the whole thing l
Marshall seven years six seven years now
since 11 yeah when I'm in 11 News and
this is your fifth Amagi returning yeah
over here yeah what is it like for you
come with us it's awesome man you know
it it continues to get better but
because like what two years ago you know
I watch the knees walk down and we
embrace and then last year was Orlando
and this year is going to be Kurt you
know I'm pretty soon when I'm gonna get
Isaac and Tori but but but not just them
talking to TD about the weight talking
to LT about talking to LaDainian
Tomlinson about about anticipating what
it was what it's going to be like by the
way I love that money you do have to now
in the football game with Lawrence
Taylor style know all that's why I did
that
better goddamn ride the elevator
knocking ha ha
yep that is that is exactly why not
isn't so I'm playing golf with like
Lawrence Taylor and I called him LT and
I said I have to call you Lawrence now
what he said I cannot say what he said
it was it was epic I bet
did you clean it up Adam there was not a
word that I feel in there wasn't like a
good word right I could like take this
blanket away like Marshall Faulk here
and the Rich Eisen show just stroll down
the hallway because we're right at the
mouth of the door through which all the
Pro Football Hall of Famers returning
you're going to go have a luncheon in a
moment Jim Kelly's going to come out of
there and kick it with us what are you
what are you thinking is now the Curt's
going your job
I'm excited for him and I just I you
know rich there's a lot of stories in a
lot of ways you get to the Hall of Fame
and things happen nobody nobody in the
Hall of Fame bagged groceries at the
high V mmm that's true he's playing
Arena League played in the World League
and then took two of the worst team in
the nineties to the Super Bowl that's
true I mean culture change Rams to the
Super Bowl and then Arizona car get to
in Super Bowl like like you know hey Eco
play for the cowboy get to Super Bowl
okay and go play for the Steelers get is
go play for the 49 you know these two
organizations were epic stat yeah you're
the perfect person to have right here um
because Brockman um does much of the
social media posting for yeah what's
going on in here so Kurt Warner was on
the air the other day and he was on our
show so Brockman posted after the show a
video of Kurt being on our program and
you posted this what you posted when
Robyn about the Kurt Warner piece you
Pro
at 13 Warner is the second member of
greatest show on turf to be inducted in
at Pro Football Hall of Fame I left out
Orlando page so of course I get tweeted
this morning by Orlando pace hey at Rich
Eisen where did you learn to count
Michigan hashtag go blah blah oh my god
and it comes directly to you uh it's all
right he doesn't know yeah yeah yeah he
thinks it's me
well this Roberts I will say your nail
friend Angelo show your names on the mug
yeah ouch that's my best technically
aeneas Williams I mean he's not a
greatest show on turf or buddy but other
he's a piece of part he's a part of the
movement of the moon called it Donnelly
he didn't win the ring he was part of a
team where he was a part of the movement
I mean yeah yeah right he helped
facilitate okay well very good I will I
will apologize to our windowpane hey I
do I do want to have you put your
paparazzi head on if you don't mind for
a couple minutes here because the news
out of Miami is that Ryan Tannehill is a
significantly missing time even though
his knees just as bad or as good as it
was yesterday there's no extra
structural damage when he went down but
it looks like surgeries on the table
they haven't decided that yet who do you
think the is the best fit for the
Dolphins should they go out and acquire
a quarterback don't care yeah now you're
talking my language Marshall is it
coming it's all very only only and only
because Adam GaSe can get color to do
the things that necessary for Cutler to
succeed Adam is one of the few guys that
Cutler will listen to he actually he's
the only guy to cover everything too
well you're talking to somebody who is
intimate with Mike Moore I'm just stupid
I know he's conversations with Mike mark
yeah I mean Adam got the best out of
Jake so I think
- easy - easy sell the problem and I'm
um what do you do because it's jab let's
say he if you look at the numbers that
he had on the hat and if he has those
type of numbers what do you do so you go
you go call him up and say put your TV
career on hold Kaepernick is not an
option you don't believe I'm gonna say
that Jay Cutler already said it was
reported that he will put his you know
not the : I keep almost to Miami man
that's seriously that that's what that
that's just what I what I heard so I
mean Jay Jay Jay is uh he's the best kid
I'm not saying don't call Colin
Kaepernick I mean you know because
they're not calling Colin Kaepernick
becomes a story you know gates you got
to understand gates Gates was he was in
Denver with Tebow you know he was the
quarterback coached in yeah so he could
actually for me he could get the most
out of whomever a quarterback is but I
believe for what they have and what they
want to do when in order to utilize the
talent that that's around the
quarterback position in Miami you need a
thrower regardless if he might joy to
the other team every once in a while but
you do either thrower of the football
more than a runner a guy who can run an
throw Marshall love you thanks for
coming down crashing in near so uh
so you think Cutler's the best fit and
that my beard is also a fit I think you
should go with a real guy actually you
got to let it just row in a little bit
more okay and just to see what it yeah
okay yeah it took me a while okay
Marshall Faulk is heading out of here
because peripherally I could see good to
see you sir there goes Marshall thought
perfectly I could just see more and more
gold jackets just walking down the
hallway as the Nitschke luncheons about
to get started and I did see Jim Kelly
who's making his way to the Rich Eisen
show studios when we come back all time
Bill's great Jim Kelly with Steve
Largent Jack Youngblood Al Michaels
Chris Collins are at them and as you
just heard with Marshall Faulk you never
know who might stop in that's what's
going down here in a very
fun day at the Pro Football Hall of Fame
live on the Rich Eisen show from Ohio
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
please download our app there's lots of
fun things there other than just more of
the videos you just saw you can call us
from the app you can email us from the
app just download it trust me you'll
enjoy